ich bin mittlerweile davon überzeugt
dass es notwendig ist dass wir an der EU
Außengrenze eben nicht mehr einfach nur
es passieren lassen können sondern dort
muss entschieden werden wer warum
weiterkommt und wer eben nicht und wer
nicht weiterkommt kommt dann auch nicht
weiter sie sagten notfalls bis hin zu
physischer Gewalt da gab's ein riesen
Aufschrei wie meinen Sie das na ja
versuchen Sie mal am Frankfurter
Flughafen durch die Passkontrolle zu
rennen man wird sie aufhalten das
Staatsgewalt der Staat setzt recht durch
und wenn der Staat oder in diesem Fall
die staatengem der EU sagt es gibt recht
es gibt Regeln wer unser Staatsgebiet
der Europäischen Union betritt und wer
nicht dann muss doch diese
Staatengemeinschaft auch in der Lage
sein an der Grenze diesen Unterschied zu
machen das heißt für mich z.B aber auch
dass diejenigen die im Mittelmeer
gerettet werden die aus dem Mittelmeer
kommt ankommen zurückgebracht werden an
die nordafrikanische
[Musik]
Küste